[Musique]
merci Roger kucci de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu des hautes scèes membres du
groupe les républicains et vous êtes le
le président du groupe d'amitié France
Israël au Sénat on va évidemment
longement parler avec vous de la
situation d'abord la situation sur place
on imagine qu'en tant que président du
groupe France Israël vous avez des
contacts que vous disent vos
interlocuteur d'abord leur
sidération parce qu'effectivement bah en
plein shabbat en pleine fête de
sous-côte et dans une période où
apparemment je dis apparemment les
relations
avec les mouvements palestiniens
notamment avec le ramas avaient l'air
plus pacifié qu'il y a quelques mois
puisqu'il y avait eu des des
affrontements au mois de mai et puis ça
s'était apaisé d'ailleurs le ramass à
l'époque avait dit non c'est pas nous
c'est le djihad islamiste bon et donc il
y avait quand même pas une certaine
sérénité il y a JAMA jamais de sérénité
mais un sentiment plutôt de calme ce qui
faisait que ils avaient autorisé la rive
partie est pas loin de la frontière qui
avaient autorisé un certain nombre de de
choses donc la sidération et le le côté
euh sidération des deux côtés d'ailleurs
sidération sur l'attaque sidération sur
la faille des services de renseignement
qui n'avaient pas vu venir cette attaque
et puis ensuite
la consternation les froids
devant les massacres devant la pluie de
roquett
j'entendais le ramas qui disait comment
comment nous exécuterons un otage chaque
fois qu'il y aura une attaque qui ne
sera pas précédée d'un avertissement le
ramas a envoyé 5000 roquettes sur Israël
je pas souvenir qu'il y a eu un
avertissement donc je voilà
aujourd'hui
le temps de la politique politicienne
est un peu derrière nous en Israël et il
est à l'unité nationale pour faire face
au conflit j'ai constaté d'ailleurs dès
hier que benigans qui est dans
l'opposition à netaniaahou a accepté de
participer au cabinet de guerre je pense
que toutes les oppositions vont y
participer de manière à ce qu'il y ait
une unité nationale totale face au
conflit et benami netanahou est très
ferme il a Pras de lui faire payer un
prix sans précédent ça vous inquiète sur
la nature de
l'escalade je sais pas si on peut parler
d'escalade la vérité c'est que le Hamas
n'a même jamais accepté la solution à
deux états quand on dit ah bah oui c'est
parce que ça n'avance pas sur la
solution à deux états que on a ça c'est
pas vrai du tout le Hamas a toujours dit
que deux états un état peu importe pour
lui une seule chose ch compter c'est la
destruction d'Israël la destruction pas
le fait qu' Israël est un État
palestinien c'est d'ailleurs la
différence entre le ramasse et le Fatar
de Mahamoud Albas qui lui dit si on
arrive à deux états bon il faut négocier
mais c'est une solution pas pour le
ramass donc je je sais pas comment on
peut négocier avec le ramass vous pouvez
négocier des trêves mais vous pouvez pas
négocier de paix le ceux qui sont en
face de vous disent mais nous peu
importe votre politique que ce soit
netanel
que ce soit la gauche israélienne que
vous ayez une solution à deux états que
vous n'en vouliez pas peu importe vous
devez être détruit qu'est-ce que vous
voulez négocier avec un mouvement qui
dit en tout état de cause nous n'avons
qu'une ligne votre destruction donc à un
moment vous redoutez un embrasement je
sais pas s'il y aura un
embrasement Israël a été surpris ça
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire et il
faudra probablement après que tout ça
soit étudié déterminé en enquêter et
Israël va riposer mais Israël bon
écoutez la France aurait reçu 5000
roquettes des commandos venant
assassiner des gens dans une r partie
assassinant 260 je précise d'ailleurs
que le le thème de la r Pary c'était la
paix la paix la paix entre Israéliens et
palestinien bon ça pas empêché 260
d'entre eux d'être massacrés sans
regarder hein donc je sais pas s aura
embrasement la supériorité militaire
israélienne est sans conteste une fois
Israël
mobilisé voilà alors j' vous dit vous
dites il y a des otages vous dites il y
a des otages et et ça c'est important le
Hamas a dit qu'il rosterait à chaque
fois qu'il y aurait une roquette il s'en
prendrait un otage est-ce que du coup ça
peut changer la nature de la
réost je ne crois pas je ne crois pas je
pense que euh d'ailleurs Israël en
parallèle a capturé un certain nombre de
terroristes
probablement nombre au moins équivalent
aux otages israéliens qui sont à
Gaza à un moment ça réduit pas les
marges de manœuvre ça en réalité le
Hamas n'en a rien à faire de ses
combattant considèent que bah sils
doivent mourir qu'il Meur a rien à faire
de sa population si elle doit mourir
qu'elle Meur dès qu'il Meur on vous dit
bah ils sont morts martyre allez hop ça
légitime tout israël est un pays
démocratique qui est resté et toujours
sur les valeurs de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen sur la
les valeurs du siècle des Lumières donc
tout être humain m en cause et
évidemment un citoyen israélien menacé
d'être exécuté c'est un vrai débat en
Israël c'est pas bah ila martyre ça ça
n'existe pas en Israël c'est une
démocratie comme la France mais à un
moment par exemple bah si vous dites
toute frappe d'ailleurs j'aime beaucoup
si elle n'est pas précédée d'un
avertissement
donc si Israël doit bombarder faut qu'il
avertisse ce qu' d'Ur je précise que
lorsque les trois tours de la tour
Palestine à Gaza ont été détruites les
Israéliens avaient prévenu pour dire
évacuer les tours on va bombarder donc
de ce côté-là on peut dire quand même
qu'il y a des rêes mais est-ce que là
une opération terrestre est inévitable
pour
vous le gouvernement israélien d'ors et
déjà le blocus complet eau nourriture
gaz électricité que vous comprenez oui
bien sûr bien sûr après tout si le Hamas
ne veut pas que ça se passe le Hamas dit
mais nous nous arrêtons les opérations
nous ne faisons plus de massacre nous
n'envoyons plus de requête sur Israël et
il y aura des discussions il y en a eu
par le passé sauf que c'est pas l'état
d'esprit du R là les populations civiles
vont payer un prix fort ah oui d'accord
mais qui les prend en otage à part leur
hamass qui se sert de la population de
Gaza comme bouclier humain à part leur
hamass
euh c'est une organisation terroriste ça
n'est pas une organisation avec qui on
peut discuter on on aurait une situation
comme ça en en 6 Jordanie avec le Fatar
je vous dirais avec qu'on aime ou qu'on
aime pas Mahamoud Abbas qu'on aime ou
qu'on aime pas le Fatar on peut discuter
avec le Hamas euh mais les dirigeants du
Hamas d'ailleurs la plupart d'entre eux
n'habitent pas à Gaza ils se sont bien
prés erv loin de là et il considèrent
que bah leur population Gazaoui est une
population qui est en réalité un
bouclier humain point donc un mot
peut-être sur le rôle que joue le Qatar
est-ce qu'il est le bras financier du
Hamas est-ce que la France doit
clarifier ses relations avec le Qatar
avec l'Iran et avec l'Iran et avec
l'Iran j'ai le sentiment je peux me
tromper j'ai le sentiment que derrière
ces opérations il y a beaucoup plus
l'Iran que le Qatar c'est vrai que le
Qatar a distribuer beaucoup d'argent euh
pour des raisons multiples solidarité
islamique peut-être mais surtout pour
éviter qu' des mouvements chez lui et
que la monarchie qatarie puisse
continuer de gérer ses affaires sans
opposition réelle à l'intérieur
euh en tout état de cause à un moment il
faudra voir ce qui se passe avec le
Qatar bien sûr il
faudra rendre les choses plus
transparentes le Qatar a semblé depuis 3
4 an
vouloir se rapprocher un peu de
l'Occident de l'Arabie Saoudite et des
états plus modérés est-ce qu'il est
encore derrière le ramass derrière le
hzbollah il faudra voir en tout cas
l'Iran lui Li est et et et l'Iran porte
une responsabilité considérable il
finance les mouvements terroristes
partout dans le monde un mot avant de
parler des réactions politiques en
France sur la situation des Français
hier soir le korsé a annoncé deux morts
il y a encore une quinzaine de disparus
est-ce que vous en savez plus non je
n'en sais pas plus euh certains de nos
collègues sont sont ont plus d'éléments
sans doute que moi non pour le moment on
a cru comprendre que il y en avait dans
les disparus entre guillemets est-ce
qu'ils sont otage est-ce qui pour le mon
les a pas retrouvé il faut il faut qu'on
voit je vois que certains parlent de 7
ou français encore non identifiés il
faut attendre peut-être encore le oui
alors attendons un peu 48 heur pour que
que les choses soient clarifiées parce
que a eu aussi en Israël un certain
nombre de personnes porté disparu qui
ensuite dans les heures qui ont suivi
ont été retrouvé attendant de voir un
peu plus clairement on va passer au
débat politique en France hier des
manifestations avant de parler de
politique des manifestations de soutien
avaient lieu dans plusieurs ville du
pays vous avez participé vous à la
marche organisée par le CRIF à Paris on
en parle avec notre journaliste mathas
sarz on rentre en jingle Mathias ah
benah si avec jingle
oui pas de
raison voilàle tardif mais il est arrivé
bonjour matthas bonjour Arian bonjour
Mathias on va voir les différentes
réactions politiques recueillies lors de
cette marche de soutien vous étiez vous
aussi à celle de Paris hier absolument à
droite comme à gauche les condamnations
tombent de toutes part hier soir il y
avait donc cette marche en soutien au
peuple israélien à l'initiative du
Conseil représentatif des institutions
juives de France le CRIF et on y a
croisé plusieurs sénateurs les
républicains notamment qui affichent un
soutien inconditionnel à l'État hébreu
Orian une sénatrice de Paris ça me
semblait évident de venir témoigner ma
solidarité à Israël euh avec ce qui se
passe depuis 48h dans cette région il
était important d'être présent ce soir
pour montrer son son soutien plein et et
entier à à Israël qui véritablement a
subit une attaque d'une violence sans
précédent inédite inouie et qui doit
être condamné la plus fermement possible
RER koti vous êtes président du groupe
d'amitié France Israël sénateur les
républicains est-ce que vous saluez la
réponse de votre famille politique oui
bien
sûrah hier j'ai vu Eric cioti on est
allé ensemble à la manifestation moi je
partage pleinement tous les propos qui
ont été tenus par ma famille politique
dans cette affaire à la fois de plein
soutien à Israël de demande de
suspension de l'aide au développement
des palestinien tant que il y a pas une
étude complète prouvant que cette aide
n'est pas détournée pour acheter des
armes pour vous il faut la suspendre
parce que l'Union européenne est
unudelle serit bien l'Union européenne
de de se secouer un peu parce qu'à force
d'étudier de faire des colloques et des
convention l'Union européenne a disparu
de la scène internationale donc à un
moment un peu de courage nuit pas on a
même le droit d'être intelligent en
Europe donc oui il faut suspendre et
puis voir ce qui se passe franchement
qui peut croire que toute l'aide
apportée à Gaza n'est pas utilisé
uniquement pour acheter des équipements
militaires pour construire des des des
tunnels pour équiper des brigades
d'intervention et d'assassins bon voilà
donc oui il faut revoir donc moi je
partage pleinement les positions d'écti
de ma famille politique Mathias il y
avait aussi des mes du gouvernement oui
après la première ministre dimanche le
gouvernement a tenu apporter son soutien
à la communauté juive de France hier à
la marche il y avait donc olivier
verrand roland lescur Stanislas Guerini
Fran rester Beranger Couillard ou encore
Hervé Berville on a rarement vu une
réaction si rapide et si groupée je
aeris-je dire face à un événement aussi
tragique soit-il en dehors de nos
frontières est-ce que la réaction du
gouvernement est pour vous à la
hauteur dans les propos oui j'attends
maintenant les actes parce que il suffit
pas de dire solidarité
compassion exaspération devant ce qui se
passe émotion ça c'est très bien
qu'est-ce que vous attendez qu même
j'attends que le gouvernement annonce
que lui-même et pour la suspension et
l'étude par rapport aux aides qu'il
apporte j'attends que le gouvernement
disent clairement que Israël a
parfaitement le droit de réagir quand il
est attaqué et que on va pas accepter
les leçons de morale de l'ONU ou de ceux
qui viennent nous dire maintenant non
non non non mais vous avez ét attaqué
massacré mais surtout ne réagissez pas
parce que quand même ça va ça va élargir
le conflit en clair faites-vous massacré
mais en silence s'il vous plaît on c'est
pas ce que dit le gouvernement Emmanuel
Macron le gouvernement mais je souhaite
que le gouvernement soit plus clair
Emmanuel Macron il est pas il il
aiché Emmanuel Macron est peut-être plus
clair que le gouvernement je dis ça je
dis rien j'attends de voir puisque il y
aura cet après-midi et demain les
séances de question d'actualité à
l'Assemblée cet après-midi demain au
Sénat attend des réponses très claires
du vous allez poser des questions oui
probablement oui mais je pense que tous
les groupes poseront des questions
demain sur quoi précisément oh B sur
évidemment l'attitude le comportement du
gouvernement français face à la crise et
il suffira pas de dire solidarité et
puis sur les
conséquences probablement en France de
ce qui vient de se passer on va en
parler justement d'abord Mathias à
gauche pour le coup là les voix divise
manifestement un malaise entre la ligne
défendue par une partie de la France
insoumise qui est visiblement celle de
condamner toute violence sans toutefois
parler de terrorisme de la part du Hamas
et les condamnations sans ambigué diront
certains des autres partenaires de
laanupes les écologistes les communistes
et les socialistes un débat qui a mené
hier nombre de manifestants je les ai
entendu à scander les slogans Mélanchon
en prison ou même de voir des pancartes
avec écrit LFI la France islamiste
est-ce que vous regrettez cette
tambouille Pol politicien à ce moment-là
Roger caroutier regrettez quoi les
positions de LFI ou laouille
politicienne dans un moment
pareil forcément j'aurais préféré que il
y a unité nationale sur le fait de dire
la lutte contre le terrorisme ne se
partage pas on fait pas il y a les bons
et les mauvais terroristes ça ça
n'existe pas ou bien vous dites ceux qui
commettent de tels actes qui massacrent
des enfants qui prennent des otages qui
envoient des des des milliers missile
bah sont à condamner point ou vous
commencez à dire ah oui mais alors
est-ce qu'on va d'abord les condamner ou
est-ce qu'on va d'abord expliquer
pourquoi je parle même pas du NPA ou de
je ne sais qui le parti indigéniste qui
disent comment comment mais continuez
donc le ramasse continuez allez-y vous
avez raison continuez les massacres bon
B de la part de Jean-Luc Mélenchon on
est dans la tambouille on est dans un
problème de valeur pour pour vous est-ce
qu'on est dans un antisionisme qui
confère à de l'antisémitisme ah dans
l'antisionisme c'est clair ça au moins
de ce côté-là il se cache même pas je
pense que maintenant la plupart des
responsables et les filles sont antis
d'ailleurs il faudra un jour qu'on
m'explique ce que ça veut dire de
légitimer l'antisionisme parce que si
vous dites en France ah non non je veux
pas qu'on dise que je suis antisémite
surtout pas dites que je suis
antisioniste si vous voulez mais pas
antisémite mais quand on vous dit vous
êtes antisioniste ça veut donc dire que
vous êtes pour la disparition de l'État
d'Israël mais ça veut dire d'autres être
antisionist
en France en
2023 on n est plus à savoir si on va
créer ou pas l'état d'Israël il existe
vous dites je suis antisioniste ça veut
dire que vous voulez donc la disparition
de l'État d'Israël comment dans quelles
conditions comment est-ce qu'on peut
dire ça il y a un état reconnu
internationalement depuis 75 ans et vous
dites je suis antissioniste parce que ça
légitime le fait d'être antisémite
justement votre collègue sénateur des
bouches du rô Stéphane l rudulier appelé
hier à reprendre sa sa proposition de
loi visant à pénaliser l'antisionisme
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
proposition bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
parce que autant je peux comprendre
qu'on dise euh un tel ou un tel ah moi
je suis très critique ça c'est le droit
de chacun à l'égard par exemple de la
politique de netanahou je n'accepte pas
sa réforme de la justice je considère
que sa manière de négocier tel ou tel
sujet sont inacceptables ça c'est la
politique chacun a le droit de dire
qu'on est d'accord ou pas avec un
gouvernement autant dire clairement je
suis antisioniste c'est-à-dire je suis
en réalité contre l'existence de l'État
d'Israël ça c'est un problème parce que
est-ce que quelqu'un dit ah ben moi je
suis antiexistence de l'équateur ou par
exemple du Venezuela
tiens personne ne dit ça donc quand vous
dites je suis antisioniste parce que ça
légitime autre chose bah oui c'est de
l'antisémitisme c'est tout merci
mathiasci à tout à l'heure on va
continuer à parler de cette actualité
puisque ça fait aussi l'actualité dans
en région on va à Lyon où on retrouve
Alexis Marie directeur de la publication
de Lyon Mag bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous alors hier à Lyon avait
lieu une manifestation au soutien à la
Palestine c'est une manifestation qui
était
interdite interdite par la Préfecture du
rô immédiatement dès l'appel qui avait
été lancé c'était dimanche soir et donc
pourtant lundi soir malgré un important
dispositif de de forces de l'ordre qui
était déployé dans le quartier de la
Guillotière qui est assez connu à Lyon
et bien il y avait une quarantaine de
membres de l'ultragauche qui s'est
retrouvé pour déployer une banderole
Gaza silence on tu Palestine vaincra et
puis de scander des slogans tels Israël
assassin Macron complice ou encore vive
la lutte armée de la Palestine au total
ce sont une centaine de personnes qui
ont manifester avec le renfort des
migrants de la place Gabriel Perry pas
d'élu évidemment et puis les CRS on ont
chargé ont fait usage de gaz lccrimogène
et ça s'est terminé s heur vous avez une
question
Alexis tout à fait ma question question
pour Roger carucci qui va concerner ce
qui se cache derrière la manifestation
pour la Palestine hier soir à Lyon la
gale qui a massivement relayé l'appel de
la fausse au lion Lyon avec un un y un
jeu de nois avec le groupe armé homonyme
la gale c'est un groupuscule
d'ultragauche lyonnais dont la
dissolution avait été obtenue par Gérald
d'hmana en mars 2022 et une dissolution
qui avait été rapidement suspendue par
le Conseil d'État faute d'éléments
prouvant que la gale trouble gravement
l'ordre public du coup monsieur le
sénateur est-ce que scandé vive la lutte
armée de la Palestine aujourd'hui bien
ça mérite selon vous que Bovo se
réintéresse à l'ultragauche
oui pas seulement d'ailleurs pas
seulement à ce mouvement-l euh tout
appel à dire soutien roamass qui est une
organisation terroriste considéré comme
telle au niveau international c'est pas
nous qui l'avons classé terroriste tout
appelle à soutenir le ramas tout appel à
dire que le hamass a raison et doit
continuer et pour moi une complicité de
terrorisme par conséquent oui il doit y
avoir des poursuites alors après moi je
suis toujours un peu euh prudent sur les
dissolutions des des des des
groupusculle euh je préfère les
poursuites individuelles parce que vous
dissolvez un groupe il se reconstitue
sous une autre appellation 3 mois après
euh il change le secrétaire général le
président et puis ciao et merci on
avance il faut des poursuites individuel
vous savez qui a organisé la manif vous
savez qui a mis en place les les mots
d'ordre et tout et bien des poursuites
judiciaires pour complicité de
terrorisme et qu'on n'hésite pas et que
la justice n'hésite pas et qu'elle soit
extrêmement sévère il en faut également
contre certains leaders de partis
politiques ah ben non mais notamment
contre le NPA moi je pense que sur le
NPA ou le parti indigéniste qui ont tenu
des propos absolument
hallucinants approuvant les attaques
approuvant les actes terroristes
approuvant et demandant même encore que
ça s'amplifie B je vois pas pourquoi il
y a pas de poursuite évidemment qu'il
nous faut des poursuites
ici en France quand il y a eu des actes
terroristes on a poursuivi non seulement
ceux qui ont commis des actes mais tous
ceux qui les ont soutenu bah si le
terrorisme ne se partage pas il y a pas
le terrorisme possible contre Israël et
le terrorisme impossible contre l'État
français il faut à un moment savoir ce
que l'on veut merci Alexis on regarde la
Une de liyonm l'inquiétant monsieur
Bagnon l'homme qui peut faire exploser
la métropole de Lyon c'est à la Une de
Lyon Mag merci Alexis avoir été avec
nous on entendait Gérald harmanin dire
qu'il y avait une vingtaine d'actes
antisémites depuis samedi est-ce que
vous êtes inquiet pour la sécurité des
Juifs de France
inquiet non
euh toujours très attentif parce que je
vois bien que certains dont on vient de
parler d'ailleurs essaent de
secouer un petit
peu certaines communautés ou certains
groupes contre les institutions juives
contre les synagogues et cetera euh je
reconnaît bien volontiers que le
gouvernement et Gérald d'an en
particulier
euh ont une action extrêmement ferme
là-dessus que la présence policière
s'est renforcée que il y a une action
claire de de de de l'État pour éviter ça
donc je pense
que les choses à un moment ou un autre
vont se se réguler et s'apprécier mais
en revanche ça me paraît clair que
lorsque des groupuscules
où des
individus contestent
euh la paix qui doit régner en France
parce qu'on a pas à importer on peut
juger on peut commenter ce qui se passe
on peut dire ce que l'on veut sur la
situation en Israël au Proche Orient
mais on n'importe pas en France les
conflits qui ne sont pas directement les
nôtre même si je continue de dire que la
démocratie française doit soutenir la
démocratie israélienne un dernier mot
Roger carucci sur un tout autre sujet
puisque dans moins d'un mois vous allez
examiner ici le projet de loi
immigration on parlait de Gérald armanin
il a fait une déclaration ce weekend
dans Le Parisien il se range à votre
position sur laame qu'il souhaite
transformer en aide médicale d'urgence
il vous soutiendra puisque c'est votre
demande est-ce que du coup vous êtes
prêt à vous ranger à la sienne sur les
métiers en tension non
oui j'avais fait voter le Sénat l'avait
voté d'ailleurs la majorité il y a déjà
3 ans 4 ans un amendement transformant
l'aide médicale d'État en aaide médicale
d'urgence euh donc je
j'apprécie le fait que Gérald daranin
trouve que finalement c'était pas une
mauvaise idée en revanche nous n'avons
pas changé de position sur les métiers
en tension non pas que nous soyons
contre toute étude mais clairement nous
ne voulons pas d'abord une
régularisation massive deuxième élément
la la le fait que cela apparaîtrait
comme un appel d'air pour les passeurs
pour tous ceux qui donc il y a pas de
compromis malgré cette main tendue de
Géral pas pour le moment sur l'article
TR concernant la régularisation des
métiers en tension maintenant attendons
de voir jusqu'où le gouvernement est
prêt à aller moi je pense que si le
gouvernement veut un texte d'immigration
en tout cas un texte en lien direct avec
le Sénat il faut qu'il revoie son
article 3 merci Roger carousi merci
beaucoup d'être venu pendant cette
première demi-ure